five fires two three  [Applause]  that's gonna scare me bloggers to the  free-throw line  [Music]  [Applause]  go  she said it  [Applause]  drinking so much  [Applause]  over there  [Applause]  notices curricula squealers  [Applause]  anytime let's say  onca Jacobo  can we have some super fashion you know  a little bit about this shout out to  spike this is drinking spiked 2.0 what  was some of his  John and talking to some of the NBA  mocking and now you have month wide open  at the top as well it's a step back yes  again  Leonard from downtown on the books take  a timeout Lynn about five to seven from  three-point land  [Applause]  Jurassic Park led by yes Drake office  [Applause]  and the franchise's first appearance in  the NBA files get the victory here in  Game one drink celebrates with Nick  nurse no massage this time just the big  [Applause]  actors are heading to the NBA Finals for  the first time in history in fact for  the first time in history  Michael the NBA Finals